[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Femi Taiwo and I
am the CTO for INITS Limited.
Today, I'll be talking about how
we build apps that scale, more
like the things we do to ensure
that our applications are
able to handle a large
amount of traffic.
So imagine you're
designing a system that
will need to send
out notifications
to users, 100,000 users,
for example, via SMS, email,
and push notifications
for mobile phones.
If there are just 10
users or 20 users,
it would be
relatively easy and it
would be executed within
a few milliseconds
or a second or two.
When you're talking about large
amounts of people, 100,000,
for example, these processes
can take a very long time.
A queue mechanism
would simply take
the data you've provided
to it and process it
in the background, and then
provide feedback afterwards
to the admin about the
status of the messages
that the admin has created.
This is an app which requires
users to verify their accounts
by entering the code sent
to their phone number
after signing up.
I have written
this code hopefully
in a way that makes it
extremely easy to follow
with as few lines as possible.
It's not meant for
production at all.
And I'm going to just fill
out the form now and put
the mobile number and submit.
Waiting, waiting, waiting.
It's back.
Great.
Now, let's take a look
at the code behind.
Here is the form with
all the elements inside.
This is the part where it
saves the information that
has been submitted by the user.
Let's take a look
at that function.
Now, I'm using Memcache just
for ease of demonstration.
This is not what I
should use, really,
but I'm using it just to ease
up the process of demonstrating
saving to a database and
retrieving information from it.
What you see here is
I'm generating an ID,
generating a code as well,
and saving to my database.
Lastly, I have a method called
Send Welcome Message, which
essentially lets me [INAUDIBLE],
which essentially creates
parameters for sending an SMS to
the client or recipient, which
is my phone number in this case.
Now, to simulate a
network or service delay,
I have this sleep
for three seconds
here, which is why you
notice that when I submitted
the form earlier, it took a
few seconds before it responded
to me.
Now, a problem
with this design is
that it means the user who just
submitted the form would have
to wait for the entire
interaction between my server
and the SMS provider to be
completed before the next page
loads, and any number of things
can go wrong at this point.
What if, for example, your
third party provider at the SMS
gateway is not reachable?
What if the service is
temporarily unavailable?
What happens?
A better design is to
simply send it to a queue.
Here's what I should
be doing instead.
When the user fills
out this form,
now I'm not going to
submit this form now.
I'm just going to
fill it out for now.
What should have
happened is that in place
of trying to connect to the
API at this point in time,
I should just add it to a queue.
I already have a method called
Queue of Welcome Message, which
helps me add it to a queue.
Let's visit that function.
Now, I'm using Google App
Engine for this demonstration.
And Google App Engine has an
awesome in-built queuing system
that requires zero set up.
What I just need to do is to
create an instance of this push
queue class, tell it
what URL it needs to call
and parameters I
should pass to it.
Then I can add that
particular task to the queue.
Now that I've done
this, I'm just
going to go ahead
and submit this form.
You notice that it
will return very fast.
Now, what has
happened is that it
has transferred to that task
and the tasks in the background.
And there you go.
SMS now is on my
phone so I didn't
have to keep the
user waiting at all.
Here are three more reasons
why queues are very useful.
In summary, if you want to
scale, you should use a queue.
[MUSIC PLAYING]